je trouve que ce qui est joli dans nos
métiers c'est quand même de dépenser
beaucoup d'argent d'invoquer beaucoup de
grand talent beaucoup d'artisanat une
équipe de dingue des moyens de la
fatigue du machin pour filmer un truc
qui sert à rien c'est la première poésie
de ce métier c'est ça mais moi je mais
qu'est-ce que je me suis amusé amusé
quoi à tourner ça c'est vraiment très
très très amusant vraiment et et le
plaisir fait comme la condition de du
plaisir du spectateur le désir des
acteurs aussi donc c'est amusant et en
plus c'est long plus c'est cool et
reposant parce que alexandre est un
tellement bon réalisateur qui n'a pas
besoin de prendre la posture du
réalisateur de faire les crises
d'autorité de réalisateur il nous en
dispense totalement elle est d'une
douceur et d'une discrétion absolue avec
alexandre s'est en plus c'est tout doux
il est tout à coup tout gentil tout doux
tout discret tout maternelle et donc en
plus d'être drôle à faire c'est cool
c'est des journées de vacances bien payé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'essaye que tout soit lisible peut-être
que j'ai fais gaffe quand j'ai écrit à
peut-être répéter le prénom de quelqu'un
ou début d'une phrase je ne sais pas
pour que juste voilà un minimum pas trop
mais un minimum de renseignements pour
qu'on puisse tout suivre deuxièmement je
m'adresse à des gens qui connaissent
très très bien ce qui s'est passé avant
c'est la deuxième difficulté parce que
je suis attendu mais la troisième que je
me suis rajouter c'est que je ne veux
pas donner assez second ce qu'ils
attendent c'est à dire qu'en plus il
faut les piéger cela sans perdre cela
donc les piéger ça veut dire comme ils
ont pensé à beaucoup de choses à mon
avis en tout cas si on regroupait toutes
leurs idées il y aura peut-être six
films à faire 10
il faut quand même trouver le bon angle
pour que tak annoncent-elles là vous
pouviez pas la faire à ma place ça c'est
moi donc
mais c'est très très intéressant
d'écrire avec tous ces trucs là le défi
est l'enjeu je pense que c'était et
qu'il a à mes yeux formidablement bien
réussi c'est c'est de faire du cinéma
c'est à dire que tout programme télé ne
s'adaptent pas au cinéma
et là encore cousinage avec les monty
python voilà quand tu as un truc à dire
quand tu sais le dirait que tu te fout
pas de la gueule des gens c'est à dire
qu'il offre au cinéma non pas un
programme télé mais il offre un film de
cinéma
le fait de finir par du long métrage
c'est une idée assez ancien en revanche
la sensation de ne pas avoir la
possibilité de finir en un long métrage
ça ça a été très clair tout de suite
parce qu'il s'agit quand même de gestes
arthurienne
parce que dessous tout ça il va falloir
boucler tous les trucs dont certains
trucs qui sont dans la geste arthurienne
et qui n'ont pas encore eu le loisir
d'être entamée dans kaamelott donc il va
falloir non seulement les finir les
volumes les commencé pour certains